hi my name is priya i'm an associate
vice president with the leading mnc bank
a proud mother of two kids a simply
learn and a purdue alumni
after working for 15 plus years and
understanding the rapid change in
technology and the dynamic disruption
the way data is going to be handled i
realized it was time for me to upskill
so when i started actively looking for
data science courses in january last
year i came across the pgp data science
course from simply learn in
collaboration with the purdue university
and then i firm my decision that this is
where i want to do it from
because i have a family and a job
moving at that point in time in my
career was not feasible at all
simply learn was offering me the chance
to get myself graduated from a premier
university without having to travel all
the way to the us
going in my main goal was to upskill and
after completing the course from simply
learn i can proudly say that now i have
upskilled myself in data science
upskilling has helped me to bring in
better solutions to my organization and
has broadened my perspective to the way
i now handle work do you know the great
thing about the course was it gave me an
option to choose when i wanted to take
the class so every saturday and sunday
when i was doing the course my husband
would take the responsibility of the
kids from 6 p.m to 11 p.m so i could
concentrate on the work with the liberty
to choose my own batch i picked up the
night classes during the weekends and in
that way it did not impact my day or my
work as such
mama i am very proud of you that when i
was studying you were studying you are
such an inspiration to the other mothers
out there who want to get back and study
[Music]
you